Come on!
Whooooa!
Let's do it!
Blast off!
Wa-hoo!
Sago Mini Friends
are ready to play.
Let me help.
Whoooaah!
Whoo-hoo!
Oh!
You're too muddy.
I'm not that  muddy.
Ok. I'm a little muddy.
Music please.
Based on the award-winning
Sago Mini World app.
Hooray!
Join Harvey
Arf. Arf. Aroooo!
Robin
Tweet. Tweet.
Jinja
Yeah!
and Jack.
I'm going to throw
Mr. Stickles
super far!
Super duper duper
most extremely
very far.
Thank you.
Thank you!
♫ We're thankful. ♫
♫ Thankful through
and through. ♫
Together,
Oh!
There's so much
to be grateful for.
Rainbow.
Pizza.
This silly chicken.
Honk!
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha.
♫ We get this thankful feeling
so we say thank you. ♫
♫ Thank you! ♫
That's stupendous.
That means it's really good.
Whoa!
Sago Mini Friends!
♫ Thank you! ♫